kendall Jenner gets a love letter from a
mystery suitor hmm and in true to all
the boys I've loved before fashion fans
are on the hunt to figure out who poured
their heart out to Kindle in a
handwritten letter
Same Same Same the bottle turned heads
at the 2018 British Fashion Awards in a
see-through gold gown she took to her
insta story to write about her wardrobe
mishap and then shared this heartfelt
letter that read in part dear Kendall we
may be miles apart but my love for you
grows stronger and stronger by the
minute my innermost feelings is a love
for you I will love you until death
separates us right now this separation
is killing me but in my heart I know
that nothing could come close to
separating us we are united into one
forever body and soul okay can we please
just start with the fact that I'm gonna
die alone you're not gonna die alone but
this is super personal and I can't
believe that this was put in a letter
how common is it to get that in 2018 now
of course people are saying that she
posted this after the event but we can't
confirm she received it the same day
this could be a late poster Kendall
Graham
oh my god it's so personal it can't be a
stranger it can't just be a fan yeah so
she's been linked to NBA Pro Ben Simmons
who is based in Philadelphia go Sixers
nuisance makes the heart grow fonder and
Kendall is on the go as a model and bed
is always traveling with his team yeah
so it makes me feel like BEC that note
would only feel right coming from him
him because we're talking about distance
and love and Watty and soul and apart
yeah it's the connection is there for
them okay clue number one
is go into that yeah exactly so earlier
this month and I witnessed lzt the
on-again off-again couple spent time
together ice-skating at Rothman ice rink
in Philly our insider ads they didn't
show much PDA but appeared to be
exclusive okay that's it that's I like
this one I like this one I'm on this one
and then fans are speculating this love
letter is the work of Harry Styles
they've been linked since 2013 here's
what we think this is a bit of a stretch
if you put Kendall's note side-by-side
with one of Harry's letters to a fan a
fan did doesn't put this together into
some freak detective work good luck
Sherlock Holmes
the handwriting style doesn't seem to
match and then when you're comparing it
to Ben's basketball autograph I feel
like that's a waste of time because they
just squiggle that down really fast for
fans yeah of course we're not
handwriting experts yet this yeah yes
by tomorrow right by tomorrow we might
be we think this one is kind of a
mismatch for Harry though what do you
think what if whoever did it got someone
to write it because the handwriting is
so beautiful it kind of seemed I don't
know I hope they didn't go that far well
we get real here is exactly of course we
want to know which suspects you guys had
in mind stick with et online for all the
latest I'm at cording underscore tez no
and I'm a - Crossin bye for now